[Music]
Vladimir Putin has set Russia on a
collision course with America and the
West Putin sees Russians as heirs to a
vast empire an empire they lost with the
fall of the Soviet Union and the biggest
obstacle to their restored greatness the
United States so Putin seeks to regain
control the former Soviet states he
wants to create a world in which the
u.s. is just another country rather than
a global leader to that end he's driving
a narrative that says if the US was just
cut down to size Russia could regain its
empire and once again be the defender of
Europe and Christianity in pursuit of
his vision Putin is creating a Hobbesian
world of violence and lawlessness his
seizure of Crimea was illegal his
occupation of eastern Ukraine again
illegal interference in US elections
illegal cyber attacks on Baltic
countries aggression deliberately
bombing hospitals in Syria that's a war
crime but Putin's Russia isn't the
Soviet Union its economy is the size of
Australia's it's population is shrinking
we can resist Putin's aggression and we
must to learn more about my take on
Russia check the link to the book rise
of the revisionists in the description
below also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI